>> All right Charles, so what would you, what would
you call let's, let's let's think about this bottom one first.
>> Okay.
>> So what would you call an approach to reinforcement learning that
what it does is it builds a model and then plans with it?
>> A planner?
>> Well, it's not a planner. I mean, the planner's inside of it.
>> Sure.
>> The overall system, this sort of blue box. Turns
transitions into policies so it's kind of a reinforcement learner.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's one that builds a model inside.
>> I would call that. You know what I would
call that, I would call that model-based learning or model-based planning.
>> Actually it's called model-based reinforcement learning.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So this is, this is, in fact, my,
you said, reinforcement learning is your favorite kind of learning?
>> Mm-hm.
>> Model-based reinforcement learning is
my favorite kind of of reinforcement learning.
>> Mm.
>> But we're not going to get to talk about it
very much, so I wanted to at least have this
slide to give people a chance to, at least, you
know, these are all pieces that you can imagine doing. Right?
This, this piece you can think of as being what
we did in, when we're talking about supervised learning. And this
piece is what you talked about last time. So you
know, you could build a model based reinforcement learner that way.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> Alright, how about this other idea, where, where you start off
with a model and then you pretend you don't have a model, you
pretend you're just in a learning situation by turning that model into,
into transitions just by simulating them.
Then the learner interacts with the simulator.
And then spits out a policy.
>> Well, I could come up with one of two answers.
>> Okay.
>> So I could try to do pattern matching on the answer to the second one. And
since that one's model based, then this one's
transition based, which is kind of cute. Or I
could say, well one difference between at least
inside the kind of blue box is it's sort
of a model free reinforcement module. because the
learner does not ever get to see the model.
>> This is true, the learning piece is model free
but we're using model free learner in service of planning.
>> Okay.
>> So, I don't know, I don't have a good
this like model free planner, or an RL-based planner, maybe.
Like I said, I wasn't going to grade it, I just
was kind of interested to see what, what you'd say.
>> Hm. Well I, I was pretty, I felt pretty good about the model-based RL one.
>> Yeah, well this
is the actual term that's used in the field. I'm, I'm sure there
are some terms that are used here but nothing, nothing really very consistently.
>> Hm. What if I called it the blue box planner?
>> You could call it that, and, but had I, had I
drawn it with a black box, it would, it had a better name.
>> mm, oo, that would have been really
cool, black box planner. I like that. Okay.
>> But but I want to point out that one of the most
successful applications of reinforcement learning are
least most celebrated was Jerry Tassara's
backgammon playing program, which used exactly this approach. Backgammon
is a board game. So we have a complete model
of it, but we don't really know how to plan
it, it's a very complex, very large state space. So
what he did is, he actually used a simulator
backgammon, to generate transitions, and
then used reinforcement learning approach
TD, to, to create a policy for that. So it,
his TD Gammon system followed exactly this, this overall pattern.
>> Yeah, it was very influential
work and generated many mildly embarrassing Master's theses.
>> [LAUGH]
I can only think of one. Oh, actually I
can think, that's not true, I can think of two.
>> Oh really?
>> Well, which one are you, you're thinking of yours.
>> Yes, I'm thinking of mine. I try not to think about it.
>> The, the other one is, Justin Boyin, who's a good
friend. And, a highly influential reinforcement
learning contributor, and now Googler. Who,
his Masters thesis was also, it's basically
another TD. He did backgammon with RL.
>> Oh, I didn't realize that. I, I actually like him. I think
he's very cool. [LAUGH]. So, I'm sure that, his was not mildly embarrassing.
>> I mean, you know, everybody's master's
thesis are mildly embarrassing because you're, you're struggling
to learn about how to talk about research,
and so you're not going to get it perfect.
>> Yeah, and in my case, it was it definitely model free.
>> Right, the only
non-embarrassing master's thesis that I'm aware of.
>> Shanon's.
>> Oh sure, alright, well Shannon. What was his master's thesis?
>> It was information theory.
>> Oh, yeah. It's pretty impressive.
>> Yeah.
>> Rob Schapire's master's thesis is pretty cool.
>> I have no doubt.
>> The boosting guy. He did, he did pom de pe learning.
>> For his master's thesis?
>> Yeah. With the diversity representation.
>> I am a terrible human being.
[LAUGH]. I mean wow. I mean it is true though, you look at someone like Shannon
and you just think to yourself, oh, for
his Master's thesis he did, he invented information theory.
[LAUGH] You know, like wow, I wonder what he did for his PhD thesis? You know
what he did for his PhD thesis? Nobody
knows, nobody cares, because he based it on. [LAUGH]
>> He, he had already done the information theories. They're like
here, fill out a piece of paper, you can pick up
a PHD. He did something on AI, I can't remember what
it was, but it was, it was totally unimportant and nobody cares
about it. But information theory? Yeah. [LAUGH].
>> Thanks.
>> All right, well, yeah, okay. [LAUGH].
>> II think, I think Schapire's PHD was boosting.
>> Thanks Rob. Make us all look bad, why don't you.